knock knock
lyric support's all there let's do
voldemort under my head scarf oh uh
sorry sorry uh did you say voldemort
under my headscarf
yeah you got a problem with my lyrics
your lyrics
no no
not at all uh i get it it's it's just um
i'm not sure
people will get it what do you mean
i don't know uh some people might find
it
offensive well [ __ ] people in their eye
sockets
we all contribute to songwriting so why
don't you give us an idea of lyrics that
work for you
yeah okay sure um okay so
uh maybe instead of
voldemort under my head scarf you could
do
i love to wear my hat scarf you know uh
less
more yay i don't know yeah maybe uh
so like maybe i i love to wear my hair
scarf
the lyrics we must carry out she's
despite my rocky start to band practice
i was feeling fine
aisha drummer she likes to vent her
displeasure with humanity on her drum
kit
she drives an uber for money her whip
is a vw golf named hands
she won't even fit she was fit mate you
see the tits are not that baggy
oh you can't [ __ ] say that with one
member
you know you don't see a lot of girl
uber drivers there
especially none like you anyway yeah is
your dad making it work or something
yeah he said if i don't drive simple
ridiculous piss heads around he's gonna
send me to iraq to marry my cousin
oh no that's so full dude that must be
funny are you starting
is she starting i'm gonna give you a
[ __ ] rating mate one star give a [ __ ]
just put on some [ __ ] music with
y'all we're your customers we deserve to
be treated with a bit of dignity and
respect
marry me should we order i do i mean we
should yeah
he's just so beautiful how is it
possible i don't understand
okay keep it together soldier pretty
isn't everything
pretty doesn't pay the bills but it does
not feed the kids
now listen if you want to close the deal
you need to show him you ain't putty in
his hands
you've got criteria i do
look i'm not saying that sarah's not
great man i'm just saying
come along tonight meet layla you'll
like her
she's always asking about you she is
serious
allow sarah no don't allow cyra
just give her space she'll come around
come on she barely considers him she
didn't tell him about her dead
sis she always puts the band first cut
and run bro
cut and run so just so i'm fully clear
on what you have just said
you've just said in front of our female
child no less
if a woman puts her work before a man
it is reason enough to as you put it cut
and run uh no no no i mean um
you you have done it brilliantly babe
you've got the family
unit and the art both coexisting in
happy symbiosis
right daughter
i think we should depart from this place
before we choke
on the fumes of this toxic masculinity
okay bye papa my uncle bye baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
that was sick what did i tell you oh my
gosh what did i tell you
that was sick she might propose to him
by now she's gagging for her husband is
kind of intense
i mean what's wrong with wanting to get
married
for while marriage was invented by men
as a way of making alliances about other
men
here marry my daughter and i'll give you
a couple of camels on this cheese bread
cheese bread it's a tool of the
patriarchy
that's just my opinion people should do
what they like
wow you've got some nerve being here
oh hi yeah i was just going leading
girls on
what is that some sort of sport for you
no
yeah no sorry listen she might look
desperate but she's not
she's a strong independent woman and you
are a sad
pathetic little man yeah that's exactly
what my mom said
sorry bye
it's actually chilling how vile he is
yeah chilling i'm sorry
no no wait no it's okay hey
hey you all right yeah yeah
it's just um what if this isn't right
listen to me you are law you're a
trailblazer
a trendsetter you march to the beat of
your own
drum i do yes it looks like i'd learned
something from all those cyra pep talks
you're the strongest kindest person i
know
i see how happy imran makes you
he's a sweet food if someone's forcing
you to wear all that you should say
something
i'm just looking for a gig for my band
is there someone you want us to call
yes please i'm
i'm desperate please please help me see
i need a slot for my band urgently
before
when who knows what might happen
are you taking the piss damn it
sorry what's going on
just relax lie down feel the earth
mother nature says chill i had never
been in the countryside before
anything outside london zone five was
foreign terrain to me
didn't feel right
whose land is this whose land is this
whose land is this
[Applause]
i mean someone went on slant i don't
know just cause someone sticks a flag
into something does it make it theirs
you get me
this land is ours we
are earth's natives our forefathers
fought and died in the white man's wars
for the express purpose
that we would be able to sit here on
this here land
and smoke this here dub
[Applause]
great
[Music]
[Music]
you